hey i'm dan huynh so i'm here with
serene tea hi I'm good thanks dan huynh
we are playing a early access build of
legends of Eisenwald this is a strategy
RPG from a small team of Belarusian
developers it's quite similar to things
like here's a mic magic or disciples or
the king's bounty series so if you're
into those you know you're going to find
this pretty cool I have not played any
of those games well I hope you like
numbers because here are some numbers
for you that determine a lot of things
and here's a sweet-looking inventory oh
I do like this is me this is my hero
that I made earlier yeah he does yeah um
this is my good friend who has a pretty
sweet beard how do you know he's your
good friend I in the story he is my good
friend okay every now and then so this
is my army at the top here I won't
really call that number no it's not much
of an army yet so what we're gonna do is
going to go find some more people to add
to the army so we're back here at
see--let's castle which is where we got
this quest to go to this castle up here
and take it for ourselves time is kind
of moving on its own and where shadows
are moving it's quite just quite nice to
change the camera angle or gonna like
the sweet River so if I go to this in I
can go to the hiring page and I'm like
I'll call these guys look cool this is a
crossbowman so he's got a crossbow and
this is a veteran wash so he's really
good at he tells us by him which is
really useful because it's not don't
leave you in the face right all right
you're gonna go to my party and you're
gonna go into my party well but now
you're making a lobster at- right on a
minus 3 90 per day because I got to pay
these people right now the thing is this
setup corresponds to what line they are
in the battle so this is the front line
this is the line behind us is where the
crossbow man and the archers go
and this is the back line so this
peasant woman heels news she's a woman
the door is pretty useful and this is
acolyte one of these bald monk guys okay
uh so that night saw as echo white sauce
so we go back and that's the tutorial
don't remember we're gonna run back to
this castle possible King it's fast
walking alright and we're gonna hide in
this finishing an idea named fishing
village yeah she's very useful so yeah
all that's left is to wait until Chris
didn't cows leave the castle very good
pronunciation there so time is moving as
we're waiting speed up a little bit
should see if I walk out of there a
minute mrs. caused at the top does oh
whoops you're right there we go ok so
wait it's a time for a siege let's go
you're about to siege that spotlight
effect is very strange yeah outside
that's just for tutorial to sort of
bring your attention to the text so
because we are seeing a castle we're
going to take damage and that's kind of
simulating the fact that we're running
the castle will get shot up by people
the ramparts and that kind of thing but
once we start the siege we're now in
learning castle so this is the hex base
battle screen and it's also turn-based
as well so the very tiny field it's it's
not much of a castle you know I say
castle but it's more of like a little
fort so my guys are all on the left and
the turn order is like this so it's
going up and the first person take his
turn is the acolyte now what he does is
he prays and bless his people which
gives them more melee damage so I'm
gonna bless my hero which is Heinrich
this guy here by clicking on him yeah
yeah he's now blessed oh this guy took
damage really uh oh oh he's dead on
maybe should have lessened him yeah okay
i'm the bestest guy oh he's won a lot of
your way yeah 10k ok Heinrich get rid of
this too
see they're down this is a battle of
epic proportions there we go he's down
and he surrendered okay hello this is
the result of the battle I lost a couple
of people look at all the sweet Luke you
got from that bracelet chain mail queef
a spear I'd chainmail Rick yeah i think
the origin of that term is something i
went out to look up yeah that's
unexpected trophies number 0 and 12 gold
toggles not that much but you know all
right i think we'll call it there that
was legends of Eisenwald fantastic
combat absolutely fantastic combat oh
that is coming out I think later in the
year and yeah well thank you very much
for watching and if you want more of
that be sure to check out the rest of
our content on gamespot com